CHRISTIAN TUEFFERS:
Welcome to the session
"Master Security and Compliance
in the Public Cloud."
My name is Christian
Tueffers, and I'm
the senior Cloud architect
with Deutsche Boerse AG.
I'm doing the session
together with Grace Morrison
from Google Cloud.
In the beginning, I would like
to give you a short overview
on Deutsche Boerse Group.
But we are a so-called market
infrastructure provider,
and as such, technology
is really in our DNA.
Our first fully-automated
electronic trading system
was launched in the late '90s.
This one is operating
on the lowest latency
networks and technology, and
together with our core location
partners, we are operating
one of the largest European
financial data centers.
All of our core
business applications
are actually self-developed
self-maintained,
and we do this with round
about 2000 people in our IT.
Our core is really our trading
and clearing applications.
As you can see, we use them not
only for securities trading,
but in the end, for any kind
of financial derivatives
trading, currency
trading, but also trading
of commodities like energy.
In addition,
Deutsche Boerse Group
is offering
pre-trading services.
So we calculate return
indexes like, for example,
the [INAUDIBLE] and the stocks.
We also operate
ultra-low latency data
feeds for our customers.
The post-trading area is dealing
with settlement and custody
services, and in addition, we
offer value-added services,
like investment fund services
or collateral management.
Everything of this is backed
by our information technology.
As you can see, we are
really a core element
with the European and
global capital market,
and as such, we are under
scrutiny of the highest
regulatory supervision--
not only by the
German regulator,
but also by regulations in
Luxembourg, Switzerland,
and the UK.
Deutsche Boerse Group
is using public cloud
as one of the main technologies
to drive our roadmap 2020.
Public cloud is
fueling our foundations
for other technologies
like, for example,
blockchain-based services.
We develop and run
blockchain-based services
for digital assets
or digital custody.
In addition, we
leverage public cloud
for analyzing big data sets
for of us or of our customers.
And we also make use of
machine learning capabilities.
So you can see, public cloud
is adding a lot of agility
into our mix, because with
this, we can react dynamically
to changing business
demands and we
can leverage new technologies
to develop new solutions
for our customers.
But we use public
cloud also to improve
the overall quality
of our systems,
and this is achieved by
standardization and automation,
and [INAUDIBLE] the
additional possibilities
which public cloud
offered to us.
As a good example, our core
trading platform, called G7,
is spinning up
every night hundreds
of test instances
in order to conduct
some kind of random tests--
so-called "monkey tests."
And then, based upon
the behavior of this,
we can improve the
overall quality.
Of course, we use
public cloud also
to reduce the operational
cost by standardization
and automation.
We are implementing a so-called
multi-cloud hybrid cloud
strategy.
As you can see on the
lower right corner,
we are not leveraging only
the Google Cloud platform.
In addition, we team up
with all the hyperscalers
in the infrastructure
as a service
and platform as a service area.
And also, for
software as a service,
we work together with
the market leaders.
The multi-cloud strategy
is important to us
because it allows us to
select really the best
service for each use case.
But in addition, it also
prevents the vendor lock-in.
And this is something which
is demanded by the regulators.
So whenever we move workloads
into the public cloud,
we have to provide a
so-called exit strategy.
The exit strategy could be
that we either fall back
to on-premise, or that
we move the workload
from one public cloud into
the other public cloud.
In order to do so, we
implemented a hybrid approach,
leveraging technologies like
container and Kubernetes.
This allows us to
dynamically shift workloads
between on-premise and to
different cloud service
providers.
Now we know, of course,
that this is not just
on a quick switch,
but in the end,
it's sufficient
that we can prove
that within a
certain timeframe, we
can move workloads
out of one cloud
and move it back to another one.
Now let's look into
the security aspects.
This picture, I guess, is
very familiar to most of you.
It outlines the so-called
Shared Responsibility Model.
On the lower part, you
see the responsibilities
of the cloud service
provider, which
deal with the so-called
security of the cloud.
This covers, typically, the
data centers, physical hardware
network up to the hypervisor
level, but also the cloud
services itself.
And also, the IT
processes in the back--
things like access management,
incident management,
or capacity management.
On top of that, you have
the security in the cloud.
This is our responsibility
as a customer.
So we have to make
sure that we provide
secure access into the cloud.
We have to define
appropriate roles.
We have to define security
guard [? trades ?] to make sure
that we don't compromise on
the high level of security
when we move into
the public cloud.
Typically, the lower
part is tackled
by looking at external
certifications,
external reports,
like all ISO 27000,
SOC [? 2.2 ?]
reports, and so on.
But the regulator made
it crystal clear to us
that only looking at these
kind of certifications
and attestations by the
better party providers
is not sufficient.
They deem the use
of cloud services
similar like the
classical outsourcing,
and hence, we need to
have the same control
mechanisms in place.
And one of them is that we need
to have an unrestricted right
to audit, that we really
can uncover and look
into the details how
the cloud service
provider is implementing all
the required security controls.
Now, if you would do this alone,
this would mean a lot of effort
for us, because as you
have seen previously,
we work with a lot of different
cloud service providers
together.
And an audit is
typically an engagement
which takes a couple of
weeks or even months,
and you'll need a lot of
people in order to do so.
On the other side,
there's also a lot
of effort for the
cloud service provider,
because it's not only us
having this unrestricted right
to audit, but in the end, all
institutes in the same area.
So for example in all the
financial service institutes.
Hence, we came up
a couple of years
ago with the idea of a
collaborative audit group.
The collaborative audit
group is an open format,
where financial service
institutes jointly
together conduct an audit with
the cloud service provider.
This has been proven
in 2017 the first time,
in a small proof of concept.
Then 2018 was really the first
large-scale audit conducted.
And in 2019 also,
Google Cloud platform
was audited by the
collaborative audit group.
Currently, there is round about
40 different financial service
institutes in the collaborative
audit group, but as mentioned,
any financial institute
can join herein.
For the security
in the cloud part,
we based ourself on the
ISO 27001 framework.
Together with our information
security colleagues,
we identified seven
focus domains,
where we put a lot of effort
into implementing security
controls to achieve the
high level of security which
we are known for our on-premise
infrastructure, as well.
So the focus domains are here
shaded in blue, and cover
things like asset management,
access control, cryptography,
and so on.
So we concluded
with our colleagues
that we needed 20 different
initiatives in order
to implement all the required
controls to cover dimension
as a domains.
So as you can see,
this is pretty much
a mix of where we extend
over the existing solutions.
A good example is
the cyber [INAUDIBLE]
for privileged
access management,
or where we identified
the cloud native services
as appropriate-- for example,
in the area of key management
and sequence management.
Sometimes, also we
identified that there
is neither a solution
on-premise available
nor a cloud [INAUDIBLE]
solution available,
and we did an evaluation
of a new tool.
A good example here is AquaSec
for compliance checking
of containers in our
Kubernetes setup.
Now, as you can see, applying
security in the cloud
is a lot of effort.
It's a lot of effort
because, on one side,
there's always new
requirements coming
from the regulators and new
security threats out there.
And on the other side, also
the cloud service providers
are always offering new
services and new possibilities.
But what we found
is that in the end,
applying security in the
cloud is something which
is the same for every client.
So it's not only us
doing the configuration,
doing the security guard
[INAUDIBLE] configuration,
the role definition, and so on.
And yet, every client, at least
under the same regulation,
has to redo the same effort.
And we thought, how could
this be made more efficient?
And the idea we
discussed with Google
here is that the cloud service
provider could take back
some part of the responsibility
of the security in the cloud
by providing things like
certified landing zones, which
are compliant by default.
And I think this not only
increases the security posture
for the clients and puts
down the barriers of moving
really critical
workloads into the cloud,
we think this is also
increasing the overall security
culture for Google.
And this is why we came into
close discussion with Grace.
And thankfully now, I'll hand
over for her to continue.
GRACE MOLLISON:
Thank you, Christian.
So Christian called
out some focus domains
from the 14 controlled
domains in ISO 27001.
Google Cloud is able to
provide guardrails and controls
to address these with native
tooling, as well as being
able to integrate
partner solutions to help
with implementing the controls.
I'm just showing
here some native ways
to help meet the requirements,
but we have a rich partner
ecosystem that can also help so
you can leverage your existing
investment in those
partner solutions.
Today, however,
I'm going to focus
on responding to these
challenges Christian set up.
How do we address
security in the cloud
for many customers, who all
have different business goals
and applications?
How do we make it
efficient to address?
How do we clearly
distinguish who does what
in a shared
responsibility model,
and what about
certified landing zones?
So Christian is right.
It's the same challenge
for every customer,
and taking a cross-sample of
the questions we've been asked,
you can see that other customers
are asking the same things
Christian has asked--
can I run my regulated workload?
What products are certified
for the regulational standard
I need to comply with?
What do I need to do to
achieve my security posture?
Our customers then say that
we also want a single place
to find the assets we need to
address our security posture.
We responded with the Google
Cloud Compliance Resource
Center.
Security Health Analytics
is an exception,
but I'll come back to that.
The Compliance Resource
Center is the way
to find Google Cloud's
compliance offerings by region
and industry, with best
practices and documentation
to support your compliance
reporting needs.
You can gain access to Google
Cloud's attestations reports
to confirm compliance with
a variety of standards
and regulations.
Google Cloud provides
a variety of security
guidance to help customers
deploy and develop
with a security-first mindset.
Customers can satisfy themselves
that they can meet the security
requirements by Google
Cloud providing guidance
and the ability for
customers to implement
the guardrails required.
We want to provide prescriptive
guidance and easily-deployable
assets which collectively
are security blueprints.
Christian, you may
recall, said what
the idea of a blueprint where
the CSP, i.e., the Cloud
Service Provider, takes
part of responsibility
within the cloud, and also
provides certified landing
zones that are compliant
by default. So we do
have security blueprints.
Google Cloud's definition
of the blueprint
provides a package of
documentation and assets,
which can be consumed all stages
of the customer lifecycle.
The intended users
are folks working
in the customer's compliance and
governance function, and also
security administrators.
They may be of interest to other
users, business or technical,
to determine, for example, if
certain use cases are feasible.
A blueprint package
varies in size,
based on complexity
of the use case.
So Google Cloud has two types
of security blueprints--
compliant landing zones--
for example, GKE for PCI--
and product and workload
focus, such as those
to Anthos, or for
your [INAUDIBLE]
the warehouse pipeline.
The compliant landing zone
blueprints have more components
than the workload
focus blueprints,
but both types have the
core components that
are the what, which explains
what controls you need
and what you need
to do, and the how,
which are the deployable
assets and instructions.
The first compliant landing
zone blueprint published
is PCI for GKE.
GKE is a Google
Kubernetes Engine.
This has a number of
deployable assets,
available in a
Github repo, provides
comprehensive guidance, includes
things like a quick start,
pre-rec so you can configure
your workstation, and diagrams,
and lots of them help known
issues and limitations
and helpful links.
Our first product-specific
blueprint collection
is for Anthos.
The first three are published.
And we are working on more.
Let's take a closer look
at one of the blueprints
in the collection,
Locality-Restricted Workloads,
but first up, I'll give you
a short overview of Anthos.
Anthos is an open and hybrid
cloud application platform,
which basically is managed
Kubernetes for GKE.
It allows you to run GKE where
you need to-- on Google Cloud,
on Premises, or another cloud.
It provides a consistent way
to manage your GKE clusters
in a secure manner.
Anthos has a
security-first approach.
It provides an auditable
and centralized workflow
to deploy conflict changes,
which both your security admins
and operations team [INAUDIBLE].
It allows you to
enforce compliance.
Anthos service mesh, which
is a key part of the Anthos
platform, abstracts
some of the lower-level
security actions
needed to secure
your microservices with MTLS
and certificate management.
Now, this isn't a
session on Anthos,
so don't worry if you don't
know what all these things I'm
showing you here are.
The key thing is that to be
able to configure your Anthos
environment to meet your
locality restriction
requirement, to enforce where
your applications are deployed
or where they can
be accessed from,
you need to consider
a number of things,
such as where your
services are located,
and you need to configure
a number of other things
to address these considerations.
So making a simple
prescriptive to configure
is the aim of the
security blueprint.
To provide prescriptive
guidance to help
our customers secure their
applications takes a village.
It starts with our
customers, you know,
so we work with our engineering
teams, UX designers, and tech
editors to show we're
delivering guides
that are not too jargon-heavy,
but validated and easy
to consume.
In effect, we partner
with our customers
so the guidance we are providing
is not creating a bubble,
and has customer input from
the beginning of the process.
But we didn't actually
stop at blueprints.
Our customers want to know
what Google Cloud products are
compliant with a given standard,
the shared responsibility
model, and what steps they
need to take to configure
those products so they comply.
So the Security Command
Center is the answer to that.
It's the canonical security and
risk database for Google Cloud.
It is an intuitive, intelligent
risk dashboard and analytics
system for servicing,
understanding, and remediating
Google Cloud Security and data
risks across an organization.
Note, though, it's
not a substitute
for audit certification
or reports
of compliance of your
products or services,
with any regulatory or industry
benchmarks or standards.
It's a guide to help you.
The key feature the
Security Command Center
is Security Health Analytics.
In the Premium tier,
it provides monitoring
for many industry-best
practices,
and compliance monitoring
across your Google Cloud assets.
These results can
also be reviewed
in a compliance dashboard.
So here's an example of the
Security Health Analytics
dashboard.
We're using in the Premium tier.
It's a single place to
view how well you're
mapping against requirements.
Now, this is a mouthful,
sorry about this--
the CIS Google Cloud Foundation
1.0 mappings have been reviewed
and certified by the Center for
Internet Security for Alignment
for the CIS Google
Cloud Computing
Foundation's benchmarks B1.0.0.
Additional compliance mappings
are included for reference,
and are not provided or reviewed
by PCI or the [INAUDIBLE]
Foundation.
And I just want to
reiterate, as I said earlier,
it's not a substitute for
audit certification or report
of compliance of your
products or services
with any regulatory or industry
benchmarks or standards.
Still looking at the
Security Health Analytics
from the Findings page, you
can click on the category,
and we'll provide
guidance as to what you
need to do to remediate, OK?
So it's a powerful
tool to help you.
So I just want to kind
of bring it all together
and talk about the user journey
to use these tools that I've
talked about.
You've just heard what Google
Cloud has done in response
to our customers' request
to make it easier,
by providing the Compliance
Resource Center as the place
to go.
Customers have many
personas involved
in ensuring that they meet
the compliance security
requirements, so I
just want to summarize
by walking through a
typical customer's journey
through the Compliance
Resource Center,
showing how the various
personas interact with it.
So it normally starts with
the CISO, in many cases, who
wants to check that Google Cloud
can meet the desired compliance
regime, and maybe
validation at this stage
what products are in scope.
If that gets the OK, then the
security admins and architects
start looking at what
Google Cloud could
be used for, and the
configuration they need
to be in, by using the
compliance map, Security Health
Analytics, and the blueprints.
And then the platform
operations security
admins and devs, knowing
what security postures need
to be met, can use the
Security Health Analytics
and blueprints to
achieve that when
they configure
their environments
and deploy their applications.
So everyone in the journey
to meet [INAUDIBLE]
compliance and security posture
are using the same assets.
So thank you for listening, and
I hope that was of some use.